um welcome everybody to session 19 of
classic metal class
scott tarrouli is here with me and we're
going to be tapping him a lot for
technical stuff but also as a fellow
since childhood metalhead we're going to
be talking about
a number of
fairly new albums so we're talking like
2018 on to
2022 by classic metal bands and
we um we're so we're doing something a
little bit different we haven't done
album reviews before we certainly like
you know
weighed in with opinions about
particular albums but here we're trying
to do something a little bit more
focused and technical and and you know
before we get started i just want to say
one thing we are going to do more of
these so you know if bands that you like
got left out you know we may be able to
get to them
originally we were going to try to do 12
album reviews eight may even be too much
as we'll find out but i put together a
list of
albums by you know classic metal bands
so we're talking about bands that had
their origins in the 70s or 80s
that were
put out between 2018 and
2020
2020 obviously there's more stuff coming
out this year
and it filled up like two pages worth of
stuff so we are definitely going to be
doing some more of these we're thinking
about doing one specifically
on new wave of british heavy metal bands
because so many of them have put things
out obviously we're talking about two of
them here with saxon and iron maiden but
um you know praying mantis and
um
who else was
not girl school but um uh
rock goddess and tokyo blade has put out
a couple so we're gonna we're gonna do a
session just on new albums by these
bands and then we're also thinking about
doing one about um not quite solo acts
but where it's a headliner like herman
frank you know or udo or people like
that so we've got plenty more to come
and you know there's probably some that
that have not made it onto the list that
that should have
um before we get started scott who are
you most
happy with
with these these albums this slate of
albums
oh wow uh i have to pick one actually
this is
pick your top three
um
i was really
uh there were some things that i went
into going i don't know before i
listened to it admittedly
yeah um
i was really impressed with the uriah
heap
okay
you know
i think the white steak is the
best one i've heard of them
um since you know in a while yeah you
know in a while yeah um
but you know i guess the main thing that
this whole topic is fascinating to me
because
we always have this thing about
you know bands phoning it in i owe an
album or let's just put out an album or
we have no budget let's do it any anyway
and um there's a difference between
these bands you know it's particularly
like maiden who
drove around on no money and uh
in a station wagon going from gig to gig
and we're talking the young and hungry
era yeah
of um people essentially living together
and
really it was about that hour that they
got on stage in a night in the other 23
hours they fend for themselves and then
you know being a little bit older
than not having that same you're not in
the same place in life
um
so i think the exercise itself was like
i call it exercise but it was
i i guess i do because we're hearing
brand new albums from classic bands not
just one but you know seeing what
kind of testing the pulse of what's
going on with these bands because let's
be
you know honest there's not bands like
these
these days there may be a few throwback
bands but it's not as prevalent as it
was say in the early 80s or the 70s
right where there were where these bands
were at least in the heavy metal area
and hard rock too just dominating and
they're pioneers yeah pioneers as well
um well let's let's jump into the iron
maiden one we got a lot of fan feedback
about this including from from ken and i
i'm going to
in a bit read um
some of his comments at full length
um scott and i have uh our own views on
on this um but maybe we should start
with looking at some of the
yeah short fan things um you want to
swap off back and forth with with this
i'll read one
are we at the top
yeah so so um
gerald sword said
overall i think it was better than
albums like no prayer for the dying or a
number of the beasts which is kind of a
strange extension there but really the
only songs i thought were really stand
out were the first three uh sunjutsu
stratego and writing on the wall it's
definitely worth adding to any maidens
fan collection but if you're new to the
band i'd suggest starting with something
else
i mean i think that kind of makes sense
the the last part if if i was going to
recommend like what album to start with
with iron maiden
right um
probably peace of mind or or power slave
or somewhere in time you know maybe
maybe killers you know
you know that's interesting that you
said that because you know we have the
diana era too
right wow that's so short though and you
know
uh you're always kind of hesitant about
recommending
um
an early singer
who is not going to stay on the scene
right
pretty much every song off killers
becomes an iron maiden standard right
but they're all sung by dickinson
throughout almost all of iron maiden's
career exactly what do you think about
the the other things you know
um
is it
is it worth adding to
a fan's collection
i have to say um i got this album when
it came out
and i listened to the whole thing and i
my first
my first listen i didn't like it at all
um and i kind of put it away and i broke
it out again i listened to it this time
i listened to it about two
three times
um
and uh it definitely grew on me you know
okay sometimes with albums
i've gone from i can't stand this album
to one day going wow how did i not hear
this this is you know fantastic and um i
think it's got some classic maidenisms
um some of the you know so i added to
the collection yeah i mean if you're a
maiden fan well the one the one i could
do without was um
oh god what's the name of it with uh
with i love the song rainmaker
okay it was what the early 2000s it was
it was more their sound was kind of
renaissance fair on that album
i kind of you know it's like that six
eight kind of
yeah yeah well i mean that kind of fits
in with the with the uh
uh the bass stuff that um steve harris
does right who's still doing most of the
writing
you know
yeah yeah yeah so i mean yeah if you're
a maiden fan put it in your collection
because um
it's it's it's definitely worth owning
you know you get the
this that you know this album after i
let the last time i listened to it all
the way through i said this is kind of
like watching a movie they were
particular about the order they put
stuff in
um much like a live set list and there
is an art to putting an order to the
song so the listener goes through some
kind of experience for better for worse
yeah and again i think you know iron
maiden is sort of
at an extreme
um for the amount of creative control
that the band has over their product and
with with steve harris essentially being
you know the the
the ring leader right um everybody else
gets to contribute but it's still kind
of his his uh
brainchild and he's smart enough to be
able to pull it off
so it's not it's just not just like an
ego trip thing let's let's take another
one uh and i'm gonna skip down a little
bit james
eight kins short and simply this album
is what iron maiden was it's
compartmentalized thematically within
the context of its preceding albums in a
way that makes it stand out from the
others akin to iron maiden's older
classic albums and the feeling of the
songs individually is true to this
feeling too that's an interesting thing
to say what do you think about that
scott
um
by the way and anybody else who wants to
weigh in on yeah we're saying
field to do so feel free to do so in the
chat sorry scott go ahead no of course i
mean i think it's it's totally fair to
say um
uh
you know
the notion of
thematic um
uh
what they're writing about like you know
especially the point of uh matter of
life and death remember when they did
that and they did the whole album live
and the american fans were furious but
um
they are kind of a concept band i mean
look we have eddie on the cover and we
say hey i really like the somewhere in
time eddie or i like the
so there is this you know um
concert invited yeah
yeah and um
uh i don't know if it was what my iron
maiden was something i'll throw out
there
technically that i noticed here is
remember
let's take live after death where they
were playing all the music up until that
point the live album
yeah yeah
the the middle sections that had guitar
two guitars they were in harmony
so they would play thirds or six like
the trooper is a great example of a riff
two guitars are playing different notes
and they harmonize right right what iron
maiden's done they've taken out the
harmony and all their epic middle
sections are octaves which are the same
note
and it just sounds really huge
i still get that great maiden effect
because
you know uh
the original players are making those
riffs but it's interesting how i don't
know if they
i'd like to ask did you did you change
with the times were you sick of the
uh twin guitar leagues did you think
that was something of the past uh
because you have three guitars now you
could stack them up any way you want so
in that in that sense the middle
sections
is i don't know if they ever abandoned
that though so
you could say it's like what made was
um
you know this is
so there's a little bit of a digression
um
on this album
you don't
you don't hear it as a album
where three guitars are like all doing
100 they're all doing work you know
there's so much that could be done
with having three guitarists
i mean you can hear the handoffs in the
soloing right so there's there's solo
sections and you know back in the day it
used to be adrian smith and dave murray
just like going back to back just like
with k.k downing and um glenn tipton and
judas priest you know like you could
hear the distinctive thing
and i on some of these songs now these
are longer songs too so there's a lot of
room to play around in the solo section
you may have like four
guitar things each with a distinctive
sound to it one more kind of tubular
and
another more biting or you know i mean
this is a very metaphorical language of
course but um
[Music]
i don't i don't get the feeling that
they really
use the three guitar thing to their full
advantage
you know and that would play out to see
them live play this material to see how
they arrange right right um because you
know with let's take the middle sections
there's definitely
a guitar line that repeats
um
and you know steve harris moving the
harmony under them which is really
important that's that's a staple of iron
maiden where yeah guitars repeat but
then the bass moves to a different
harmony or a different note
and
the sentiment of what they're playing
kind of changes like the trooper again
we all know the trooper if we go back to
that they're playing the same thing but
what makes that so dangerous sounding is
the base moving right right and if that
wasn't there we wouldn't you know the
base is so important to that riff you
know something else that i noticed in
terms of the the mirroring that's going
on there's quite a few songs on there
where it's uh it's you know you do often
have like the bass mirroring the guitar
to like provide extra heaviness right
and then steve harris goes off and does
his thing there's a lot of songs on this
where at least for part of the song
um
it's bruce dickinson's lyrics that are
being mirrored by the guitar going like
note for note and there's even there's
even one where the base is doing that
and i don't remember
offhand and i'm not saying in my notes i
don't think i wrote down which one that
that was but there's a there's a lot of
that going on
and um
i wasn't quite sure you know
is it gimmicky is it uh no good
musicianship
you know chico's the first one
i think on the album where the guitar
does plays an octa fire it really
reinforces because
you notice on the chorus on some of the
courses bruce dickinson's notes get
longer so there's not as many lyrics
there's not and then having the guitar
like an octave higher
copying the phrasing it's not gimmicky i
i don't i don't think so uh it
definitely adds to
um it's a clever way to reinforce
um to fill up the sound of the voice or
maybe enunciate the words
um i don't know
i don't know what the uh
i'm not sure what
their reason is but um i did really like
that that was that struck you know how
certain things when you listen to what
struck you as maidenesque
and then you know actually
what the last album that we're going to
review la guns there's a few solos in
there where you're like this kind of
sounds iron maidity
i have that in my notes
you know uh
which is which is interesting
yeah i mean um
but you know that's a great observation
that
especially in the choruses the guitar
would reinforce the phrasing
of the vocals and i actually liked it it
does have a nice effect to it
yeah um the way that they use it but as
far as like back to your point of the
three guitars um
i'd like to hear them do the material
live because even
i didn't understand when yannick first
joined the band even for the first 10
years it's like
they would double the trooper solo or
they would he would double or take over
adrian smith solo
and you know i didn't think live they
were using it they did overdubs on
powerslave and all these albums
but they weren't reproducing the album
they were just doubling or
um doing things that i mean just
personally
if i was musical director i'd say don't
do that but
i'm not legendary you know i yeah if i
had the if i had the great ideas i'd be
iron maiden well and if you and i if you
came in and started saying that steve
harris might shut you down anyway and
say listen you're not the boss of of us
that might be the best thing that ever
happened to me having steve harris shut
me down
[Laughter]
you know so so ken has a lot of really
cool comments here and and
ken's here in the uh
session as well we're really happy to
have all these things so uh he said
lots of thoughts
on this apologies in advance for the
wall of text but it's very well
organized there's a lot of good stuff
there so the first point
for me senjutsu represents peak maiden
what do i mean by that a couple of years
ago one of the band can't remember who
it was though it may have been nico was
being interviewed and explained the
reason the band never got air time
outside of niche metal shows was that
they preferred longer songs that didn't
synergize with radio shows that tend to
prefer lots of shorter songs
this in turn was the reason the band
adopted a relentless global touring
calendar because in the earlier days it
was the only way to substantially
increase their fan base
they appear on a lot of pointless best
rock compilation album ever number 47
but in the same way that they all
feature paranoid for sabbath the iron
maiden track is always run to the hills
or or the trooper or whatever right
maiden always have a longer epic track
on their albums i think that's right and
actually most of their albums have more
than one longer epic track so um what i
mean by peak maiden is sanjitsu has
three longer epic tracks those being the
last three on the album
why oh so this is really interesting
clearly steve harris likes writing them
and when a band reaches this level of
fame nobody's going to make demands of
the band in terms of what sort of songs
they have on an album
they also feature the sort of catchier
shorter tracks that have been evident on
made in albums since brave new world for
those who prefer the shorter or single
type songs and so i think that's
that that seems right to me what do you
think
yeah i was going to point out um the
last
few songs
um
were great experiences on this album and
i was like uh well you know it's i
always loved like seventh son of a son
the song
because they bring you through so many
different moods and they they're not in
a rush to get out of a section
um that's a good way to put it yeah
they're not in a rush and they're
letting the listener kind of ride
that um
and they even did it on somewhere in
time to agree like loneliness of a long
distance runner maybe that wasn't a
super long song but the
the what i call the kind of the dreamy
guitar in the middle where
um they go into different uh like they
might go into a half time um but
they let you kind of zone out
and then they come bring you back into
the tune in a different way so and i
would say the long songs are are very
clever and uh i enjoy the journey
through them with iron maiden because
they're not just ex they're not in their
experimental phase we're like oh let's
just put something in seven or less you
know and there
there's also you know like we want to
talk about like a classic formative um
phase up to like maybe
somewhere in time you know um
number the beast has hallowed be thy
name
same sort of dynamics that you're
talking about and then exactly peace of
mind has to tame a land yeah you know
very dreamy and then it's got these you
know very different types of sections in
it
um
we should uh
uh pause for a moment take take the
question so mark
says this might seem like an odd
question but i'm unaware of iron maiden
ever been accused of something like
orientalism just curious based on their
aesthetics over time
wondering now looking at the new album's
cover i mean i think everybody who's
possible to accuse of orientalism has
been accused by somebody who wants to
try to write an article or you know make
a point on twitter or something like
that i think that the question would be
is it can you make like a substantive
claim and when we're talking about
orientalism here the reference point
would be edward saeed's book orientalism
um and you know i don't know that it's
um
that it's a very good
critique of of iron maiden's
stuff so
ken also says it's interesting some of
their old stuff played live these days
is subtly different from the original
recordings new parts are introduced for
yannick
um
yeah so that goes back to what we were
talking about earlier mark says maiden
have some beautifully atmospheric metal
moments that's a good good word
that's exactly what in in it's when i
was in high school
you know people that weren't into metal
would say you know this i just want to
bang my head and this makes me so angry
and i said no this is very this is
really dreamy this is like you know
really relaxing and my mind can flow
because
um
the
the way they sat down and put these
things together was so clever i mean
they're huge pioneers of it i mean
there's people we could go
stop copying iron maiden to people you
know it's like
you know if they do something
they're so but i i agree with that mark
um beautiful atmospheric metal moments
and that's how i always saw it was like
those middle things are just like those
middle parts or seventh sun when it
comes out the whole ending is just i
used to just listen to that whole
three-minute ending with the solos and
the the different parts it was just very
yeah
it was great so ken brings up an
interesting point then we'll jump back
into ken's stuff maiden were accused of
satan worship after a number of the
beasts people would buy the albums
publicly burn them and run away from the
fumes yeah i mean we all remember the
satanic panic um when geraldo rivera did
his uh his just terrible expose my mom
actually went and took away my sister's
albums but not mine i'm not quite sure
why
and it only lasted a short while but
back to uh and
we probably won't get to everything that
that um
uh ken says here but there's a couple
other really good ones
um third point sunjitsu is also peak
maiden in terms of sawing subject matter
they've traditionally had tracks about
history and anti-war on most of their
albums this is no different while many
bands are content to have tracks about
sex drugs and rock and roll on sunjitsu
we have a track about the ancient
parthian empire a song about depression
one about the mongol invasion of
medieval japan one about a future
ecological collapse intelligence
songwriting has always been a staple of
maiden yeah and i think that's true i
mean
and it makes it kind of interesting you
know when we were doing like our thing
on power ballots
or talking about romance there's not a
lot of that in iron maiden like judas
priest you can find um
stuff like that you can also find like
you know dirty songs so to speak i mean
the closest thing that you really come
to that in classic maiden is revelations
right she came to me with a serpent's
kiss you know
yeah they're not about like let's party
you know rock and roll um all night or
something like that it's
it's deep stuff right
yeah i mean even oh mark points out
charlotte the harlot so there's there's
an exception charlotte the harlot and 22
acacia avenue right 22 car cash
uh
those aren't about screwing really yeah
exactly it wasn't really a romantic
romantic thing it was uh
what do you think about this fourth
point the musical skill of the band
members is fully on display
um i don't think it's too controversial
to say steve harris is the best bassist
in all of metal his skill is on display
here bruce's voice is aged and matured
he can't sing these days as he did on
number of the beast but you know show me
a singer whose voice hasn't even and he
refers even to like dio dio you know we
know had to stat had to tune things down
quite a bit but he still had the same
power in his voice
um
rob halford is interesting ken brings up
not not even halford sounds like he did
on painkiller
yes but
i saw a performance of painkiller where
halford like pulled it off and it was
almost like an athletic
performance you know you and you could
tell he was using his body to to full
advantage in in doing that he's using
like these music or these singers tricks
to get like the full amount of sound
because that's a that's an incredibly
tough vocal
song
um but back to um
to this so
you know are they firing on all
cylinders
i think they are i think ken's right
about that what do you think scott
um i don't know if i
um
well
just
the first thing is d.o
i think his voice got better and better
really
oh god i loved you know i loved his
voice early on but it kind of definitely
got deeper and
his friends got more mature and the
power was still there and um
yeah you know like
although i never heard
dio i saw him live in the last few years
too
and um he was on fire and the band was
on fire as far as are they firing on
also i mean
um
i mean
they sound great they sound fantastic
and i have a note here
um
there's a melody that
bruce dickinson sings on this new album
where uh the melody is incredible and
the way he executes it is incredible uh
uh
it it's on the first disc
but anyways i don't want to i'll find it
but i i won't
this is a good place to talk about um
not just you know musical dynamics but
also some of the songs i do want to say
one thing about
um
the musicianship and it's not so much
about musicianship as such it's more
a small criticism
having to do with sound and i'm it's
kind of a surprise to me like you know
steve harris's bass
technically is really great
but the sound to it feels kind of dry i
would say kind of hot like there's more
high end you're not getting like a
heavyness to it and i can understand why
steve harris might want to do that
because he'd spend so much of his time
walking off of the
the baseline into fills and stuff like
that
so you you want to hear it but i i kind
of felt like
and so i guess this would be a
production thing
um i would have liked to have heard like
a fatter fuller heavier sound to his
bass
the the thing that happens with all
metal albums and it surprises me but um
and i said this earlier before we
started um
i agree with you greg on that um that
you know if you listen to the older
records you you hear the richness of his
base you know that's a good way to put
it yeah no um
but you know when they came out with the
remasters of all their albums in the mid
90s they were well late 90s they were
complete junk and um
because the trend in
we always say it mastering will make or
break an album so my iron maiden will
record yeah i'll have somebody mix it
fantastic and it probably sounds unreal
but you have to master it
and what they do now is they just make
it loud there's no dynamic range the
what i mean by dynamic range is it's to
a number system
and this is something to think about
when you listen if you're
if you're stereo so volume knobs on
three and it already feels super loud
and the more you turn it up if it turns
into white noise
um
you know just
if you think you forgot a b with an
original pressing of peace of mind
you'll hear okay a huge difference so
what they've done is
the the record companies or whoever says
our album has to be louder than the next
band's album
and that's really what they do and they
there's a sort of diminishing return
with that right i mean you can only get
it so loud
well we have volume knobs on our system
you know right um but they they think
well this will be someone's itunes
player but we have that in itunes where
they'll it'll keep it compressed all the
songs don't jump out at you yeah um but
on this album i'll say it's it's it's
bordering white noise and what the first
masters i i got somewhere in time and i
was so disappointed because the snare
drum would disappear when the voice came
in and that's because they've done this
right right and everything can't exist
and it would shove things out of the mix
of the snare drum would disappear
in the song somewhere in time when bruce
dickinson would sing and i wanted my
money back
and um
you know
i i i
i have a a student that's in a hard rock
band and you know they
they just finished opening for slash and
seven dust and all these major bands but
their album
is i i said to her i said you know how
much control do you have because the
mastering is makes your album almost
white noise yeah she said she hadn't
even heard it
oh wow you know so i wonder if like what
they hear it they think it's great they
send it off and it goes off to the
masses i i don't know if they get a copy
of the cd and they listen to it that
happened with gene simmons actually they
had to tell him the the kiss catalog
need to be remastered he went out and
bought every kiss album listen to him
and said this is unacceptable so ken ken
says pretty sure the 19 the 95 to 98
remasters were pretty much disowned by
the band the 2015 or much
yeah 2000 yeah 2015 absolutely i agree
with you ken so let's because we don't
want to spend the whole time on iron
maiden let's talk about like you know a
couple favorite songs you know the the
title track should always be
something emblematic um i thought it was
a really solid piece and jutsu what did
you think scott i thought it was okay
it's not on my hot spots list okay what
would what would be your favorite one
from the
oh gosh favorite one i have a few hot
spots stratego i liked a lot okay um
that's one where the the vocal was
doubled the note octave it's got that
classic maiden gallop that one reminded
me of like the stuff on brave new world
which i love that album yeah you know
that's an amazing record um
days of future past great rocker that
was my favorite from the
and um
i like their use of synth it's it's very
uh it's very minimal but it almost
sounds like an old synth like yeah
so this is something that i wasn't going
to talk about but since you bring it up
on that song it's great i think on some
of the songs there's too much synth like
it's there constantly
and
it wasn't necessary and it detracts so
for example the parchment i think it's a
decent song that i like the guitar parts
i don't like the synth in the background
you know and i i kind of felt there was
just too much of it
okay
i mean we're not in turbo land though no
i mean
um
well you know greg and i always uh
mention as we were growing up
how the album was unfolded and the shock
we got from you know when turbo came out
right it's kind of like you know we got
to be there on release day we put it on
our turntable or for a lot of people
somewhere in time
where you know it was the shock we got
from what happened
yeah
it's just a rainbow
um
but yeah days of future passes and it um
that's the one that had the great melody
i have that as a note is that bruce
dickinson delivers on that chorus it's a
great melody and the way he sings it is
just
beautiful it's um
you know it's a good point about like
how he can't sing the way he used to but
i really love his voice now yeah you
know robert plant he can't sing the
zeppelin stuff but god does he sing
great
you know um
[Music]
yeah but like uh i don't know if singing
the early stuff is
it means uh they're they're as good or
better technically they can hit higher
notes but if as your voice matures
is it is it you know is it a good
sounding voice is your phrasing great is
your in other words if i showed somebody
the first time i've never heard of
maiden would they say that's a great
singer absolutely yeah he's surprised
well this is an awesome segue into the
next album and the next band if you're
gonna do iron maiden you obviously have
to do juice priest right because they
they've been rivals essentially
uh you know most of their career for so
many reasons and
this is an album where halford's voice
sounds great oh my god um
and he has the range you know that he he
always had he can go down to the deep
crooning
bassy stuff he can do the growling well
it's not you know technically growling
but it's it's the closest that he gets
to it and then go up into
you know the really high octaves without
um becoming a falsetto um yeah now this
is a little bit of an older album
firepower
uh from 2018 we actually got to see
[Music]
them play stuff from this twice live
once with uriah heap and once with saxon
and black star rider here in milwaukee
and they um you know this is actually
something scott wanted to talk about too
they you know they supported the album
they they mixed in
well i actually went to the setlist they
they did firepower lightning strike evil
never dies necromancer specter and
trader's gate on those those two tours
so that's
yeah i mean that's six out of 14 that's
that's supporting the album
exactly i always say minimum five
oh andy andy has a few things going back
to the maiden thing if i was introduced
to maiden through this album and the
first thing i heard was the writing on
the wall i wouldn't really dig it
yeah and and the video with that i i you
know i may be a little controversial in
saying this i thought was just awful
just too many things all packed into
like a whole set of tropes uh now andy
brings up when bruce dickinson did his
spoken word event and he left the stage
before playing the video the chatter and
the crowd overheard as we were sitting
there was not the the greatest either
yeah i mean i gotta say that's a weird
one to make a video because that's i
mean that that beginning is
an annoying to me because it's got that
cowboy kind of exactly yeah yeah and um
you know i don't want to criticize but
it's like they think they are tesla
well well right you know it's it's you
know the first thing i thought of is
like they're going to want to dead or
alive land
you know
which i love bon jovi i'm not but
they're but you have to keep them
desperate you know made in here bon jovi
you don't want to venn diagram of them
you know what that's exactly yeah yeah
there's not a lot of overlap in that
case
um now um
there were some good comments um
so
the flexistentialist wrote firepower
delivers what many of priests
contemporaries inc including priests
themselves have lacked for some time now
it's uncompromising in its essence
vicious and an unapologetic a worthy
addition to their legacy i think that's
that's
pretty on point there's every song is
um
you know on point um even the ones that
are kind of soft
like sea of red um get harder as they're
going through it there are a few songs
where you're like this is a decent song
i see what they're doing
it's not one that i'm going to say is
awesome
but there are some
songs on there that are really good
you know
i i i just thought this album was
amazing
i mean i was floored and how great the
band sounds i mean
you know this is another thing that i
was really listening to does this sound
like a band
and
you know uh not so much listening to the
guitar solos as
the bass drums and guitar lay the groove
is the template
and yeah i mean they
hit it out of the park i think and the
songs i love so much and
um well speaking of the guitar solos i
just think all of them were really
tasteful like a lot of the beginnings of
the solos weren't like the normal cliche
stuff that somebody would start in rock
like it was a nice melody to start to
bring you in and there were some
rhythmical surprises i mean i thought
the playing was very thoughtful yeah
very good and you know and this is the
last one that glenn tipton was fully
able to contribute to priest has got a
new album supposed to be coming out this
this year but it's
you know
because of his parkinson's disease glenn
can't do everything that he used to but
richie richie faulkner is on fire in
this
he's a great player
um the vast v wrote uh i think this
album really solidified priest's
reputation as legends of the genre yeah
in addition to that that they were in
their 60s when they released the album
made it twice as good um favorites
include firepower no surrender and you
know yeah i think that's
that's kind of right i mean you could
say well priest's reputation was already
solidified
well
yeah but there were some missteps you
know and
there's a lot of bands that are kind of
just like living off their legacy and
not producing
really good new stuff
they're just playing the old stuff um
this was like a a great new contribution
no i you said it perfect is um
i guess that's what i was trying to
articulate earlier is like are they
gonna come and just phone it in you know
everybody's like well
you know where's where's are you guys
gonna do a new album when the fans
usually don't want a new album
you know they you know um
you go to the show
um i mean i already brought this up but
when maiden did a matter of life and
death
they did the entire album and you know
my friends that saw the tour said
everybody just started sitting down
after the third song and then they
played like four classics after four or
five people got up and people like went
but you know people wanted their money
back and i say well don't go to that
tour then i mean
i think it's cool that they played the
whole album because this is you know
like for this this is just priest 2018
it's not 1982 anymore yeah
they could play the 82 songs but they're
not the same people and this rep should
represent where they are now and they
sound like
pros they're absolutely you know and in
concert when they when they play some of
the older stuff
you know like um green man alicia or you
know something like that
they are playing it
basically with the kind of um tempo and
drumming and distortion that's
characteristic of them now they're not
playing it like you know early uh 80s
you know um it's it's uh it's changed a
bit ken had some some uh good stuff here
i didn't expect i admit i didn't expect
them to make an album of this quality so
late in their career i thought some of
their more recent albums were below par
from the band redeemer of souls is
particularly weak though i did enjoy the
concept album nostradamus priests were
definitely firing on all cylinders when
they wrote and recorded firepower
um
and he he talks about um you know richie
faulkner
um
this is
so i think there's a really good point
this is sadly probably the last time
we'll see glenn tipton have any creative
input into the music of priests but i
think it serves as a fitting testament
to his abilities over the years
um he talks about andy snape as well
and then he says halford is also on fine
form here his voice is obviously matured
like scott's talking about and he can't
quite sing like he did on painkillers or
defenders of the faith but then the
music has changed
rather than being balls to the wall
metal like painkiller was i think
firepower demonstrates a much more
versatile and even emotional priest on
tracks such as children of the sun one
of one of my favorite ones great and
rise from ruins
um tracks like the title track and
lightning strike exhibit a more
traditional pre-sound and aggression so
i think those are those are all very
good comments those are all very
yeah on point
um andy says firepower was so good and
so heavy that when they first started
playing it live when we saw them on that
tour i felt like it was something i'd
heard before but couldn't place that's a
good one andy
you know what
a new record has to be that good the
songs have to be that good that if
you're hearing it for the first time in
the show and you're expecting
you know all the classics if your ears
perk up going what's this and they've
made you want to go to the merch booth
and buy the album yeah um that's
i mean that was the point of playing the
songs on the tour was you know to get
everybody to buy the album i'll actually
say something kind of face andy and i
are married and
her mom came with us to that show uh the
one with uh saxon and black star riders
uh when the the the fire power tour was
first taking place and we went to the
merch booth and we got her seven yeah
dandy's 75 year old mom
a firepower shirt which then she put on
during the concert
you know that that's so cool because you
always got the t-shirt from the tour
when we were younger that was the cool
thing
and i love when i feel like
we'll we're gonna hopefully get to
blossom but when i the times i've seen
them they have the symbol remains shirt
and you know i'm one that i have to have
the dates on the back right you have to
have the dates on the back for the tour
yeah
yeah so um i mean the whole album i
don't think there's a uh a misstep on
the entire album i have stars next to
almost everything
so
so obviously you're not gonna have a
favorite one
uh well children of the sun is up there
yeah because the the
i call it a halftime dismal rocker i
love
i love that the dismal guitar
riffs when they come up like um
or you know uh i always love how
dangerous heads are gonna roll started
that opening for head's gonna roll is i
could listen to that intro forever i
it's very simple but it's so cool yeah
um when you get a guitar part alone that
makes a um
that that has a
an emotional reaction but it gives me
emotional reaction
and it's got helfer doing the sort of
like um crooning
you know that he would do on like sin
after sin or you know later things as
well and then you know
pushing up into the
the uh uh higher range as as it goes
into the heavy parts i i think the solos
on it are really good too that's amazing
they're fantastic
i also really liked evil never dies
um
i
probably think that's my favorite one
it's a very heavy song you know
yeah and it's got the um
the cool double kick on the chorus which
is like you know we all know right right
it's got the
when it's not like the really fast it's
the kind of like eighth note but it's it
it's it's a certain
um
punch to the groove to
you know there's different ways you can
enunciate stuff with rhythm
and uh
that's one of them i mean sometimes
going to halftime um
which they do sometimes
the first solo in one of these songs is
quiet but double time and then it gets
louder and goes to halftime which is
really interesting
somebody thought of that and like
listening to it like made
complete sense quiet faster
yeah halftime loud and it really had an
impact when it went into that halftime
thing and it was just like yeah if you
were at that show you'd probably you
know
yeah
no that makes that makes perfect sense
uh anything else that we should say
about priest because we do have to like
keep moving at a a decent clip uh i just
will say that um the last track was
really cool and appropriate you know
kind of the acoustic intro with the two
guitars i did kind of like how they
wrapped the album up with it
you know
um listening to an entire album you you
do want uh some form of experience and
some kind you don't want a collection of
tunes they throw together at random so
it's kind of like yeah um
it was it was a nice thing they had like
a shuffle as the second last tune which
was like a rock shuffle and then into um
into that acoustic thing was was really
pretty sweet i like i love the album
so the next one that we're going to look
at is also you know from the same era
also you know a band that at least
started out as a british band
um white snake uh you know nowadays it's
incorporated a lot of other uh people
from from here and there they they put
out a
album in 2019 called flesh and
blood and it seems like um
people's takes on this are a bit
you know more well some of this is good
some of this
not so good
um ken bourne said i enjoyed this album
coverdale does an admiral admirable job
on the vocals i like the heavier tracks
like good to see you again shut up and
kiss me troubles your middle name and
get up after all's a nice ballad but the
product is missing some of the blues
influence that laid the foundation of
their early
albums um ken said um i find it very
hard to be objective about this album
because i do and always have despised
hair glam medals well that's okay right
but flesh and blood is sonically decent
and has an excellent production
coverdale's on fine form
here's a really interesting comment for
me the real problem is this is a good
example of a band that has failed to
evolve perhaps not in terms of the sound
and production which i think is i think
is right but the sawing topics
the lyrics this is hair metal straight
out of the mid 80s in the worst possible
way best example is shut up and kiss me
a song that i'm not a big fan of by the
way too no and they made a video for
that that they pushed that as their
single i think right you know actually
so let's pause here
maybe
at a certain point you know coverdale 70
now um maybe at a certain point
you
you do have to like move on beyond the
innuendos and it you know it's about
slipping it in and stuff like that slide
it in right that's right yeah
think i have a black flag song rather
than white
which is all you know
there's no innuendo in the black flag
one um
so you know
i i think there's there's there's really
something to this
um i actually thought coverdale's voice
on some of the tracks it's it's like
really there and it's the david
cummerdale that we we know and and you
know remember from all the way back and
you know deep purple
on their last couple uh albums into the
the white snake band
um but on some of them i think his voice
there's it it feels like restricted it
feels like
they were like don't don't try too hard
david you know
um some of the some of the ones where i
thought his uh
his voice was really
coming through
um
when i think of you color me blue you
know
um
which other ones that i put in here
there were a few other ones we were like
yeah okay that's definitely
the david coverdale that we know from
you know early 80s um but some of the
other ones you're like ah
he could he could go ahead well i was
just going to say you know um
is
before i forget as far as the classic
white snake sound i thought there was a
bunch of it on here because the first
two or three songs there's slide guitar
you know they're like um
joel or i think joel holster he's
playing slide guitar and that's like the
old early white snake that's like when
it was the white snake blues band yes
right and um
and you know i never
i never put white stake in the i mean i
guess they had the look of glam but they
you know that 87 white snake out besides
here i go again is a pretty heavy album
bad boys
um
you know it was like the post zeppelin
mastered to me so i think that in that
respect they're sort of like rat right
rant gets classified as a glam band but
they're they're darker and grittier and
heavier you know yeah i mean john sykes
is a nasty guitar player from thin lizzy
i mean you're talking about the purple
thin lizzy all these members so it's
hard for me to
say they're a
white snake's a glam band um they're not
they're not glam and like the way poison
is or cinderella
yeah i mean even cinderella is pretty
raspy and bluesy i mean i always
you know i thought
i always thought calling a band
a a hair band that was that was made up
by uh i remember when mtv made up that
phrase because they wanted to bring in
their new hair metal which was grunge
yeah where nobody took showers where
everybody wear flannel you know and
nobody played in tune everything was
reactionary and so they made up this
thing that you could discount a band
simply because they had big hair and um
that's short-sighted i think
um
that's just my opinion um because i
wouldn't call this the singer on bern
a glam metal guy you know the the the
guy on the deep purple records the guy
that played
um well it depends on context though i
mean andy actually brings something up
that i think is kind of germane to this
so she says i would love to hear what
scott thinks about coverdale page as
being the direction coverdale really
wanted to go oh that's a good time as a
reason for the later white snake albums
feeling completely non-committal but
also if you think about like robert
plant right so when robert plant is in
zeppelin
that's a context and he can sing a
certain way and and by the way andy you
know can tell you you know some
interesting stuff about having seen him
live and
um how like his demeanor changes when he
sings zeppelin stuff and then when he
sings like you know is it the honey
dippers well that's a very different
context
and it's the same guy you can do can do
both so whether or not a band is is glam
kind of depends on
you know the
what's environing it i think you know
i i guess i mean the content of the 80s
you know i wasn't a uh well
speaking of uh
uh the the the follow-up album slip of
the tongue i did i didn't like that
album at all it was just like they were
trying to make the 87 album happen again
and yeah the magic wasn't there but um
but the 87 album i think is classic as
far as this new one like this the slide
it went back to like the bluesies
there's a couple actually bluesy tune um
what track is this flesh and flesh and
blood i would say is pretty bluesy
you know yeah i mean um
i thought it was a pretty solid album
for white steak their last few albums i
i didn't really you know they did the
purple album they did the blues out but
then there was the one
um
maybe five six years ago and i can't
remember
the the album uh i have it but i was
like eh
it's cool
but it didn't like it wasn't like
something i needed to hear live yeah
but basically they did a good job i
really liked uh track four hey you you
make me rock it's kind of a classic
heavy song it's got a you know john john
lord style organ
yeah great driving riff they used
coverdale's voice on it
um it goes into a lighter bridge which
then has like a blazing guitar solo you
know like that's for me that was kind of
the standout
yeah that was a that's a great one
i have uh
what's the second track
gonna be all right that's another really
good one
yeah i have a star next to that one i
thought that was uh there's more slide
in that one and it's like
the riff was kind of um
interesting
tell me if you think i'm i'm completely
wrong about this i put in my notes
kind of queen's right feeling riff and
progression at first
oh i
i don't think that's
that's the that i didn't hear it that
way but i wouldn't say no way man i
think it's it's the sort of thing like
if you didn't know it was white snake
you'd be like that could be queens right
at least that's the way it sounded to me
you know that's an interesting point
like if you were to play it for each
other but not say what it was
yeah well you know on that that mark
like shut up and kiss me
uh
the intro
you could be you could be like well
that's joe satriani
yeah that one you know what's
interesting i mean i don't know about
you but like
nine times out of ten when a band pushes
a hit it's my least favorite song on the
album
oh the one that's supposed to be the big
single
yeah and this one
actually going through and doing a
little research i found that video for
shut up and kiss me and i go oh i get it
now this is this is what they said we
need some kind of hit david it's like to
a 70 year old what do you mean some kind
of hit like
you know you're already established your
fans are gonna you know hopefully buy
the record and
um now i'll be i did not do my research
i am gonna go see them
um but i'll be curious to see how much
they back this album up how much is in
the set yeah andy and i have tickets to
see white snake with the scorpions
on the same tour
and i think there's there we should ask
a similar thing about the scorpions why
don't we jump into the third thing
because that's that's you know another
really uh classic metal band um got a
new album
right out um
rock believer
and it's you know well so ken has a good
good analogy here he says the best way i
can describe what i think about this
album is with a food analogy
foodies of which i am one often imagined
huge incredibly elaborate feast made of
all sorts of exotic ingredients that are
cooked in unusual ways
however sometimes all one needs is a
really good quality ham and cheese
sandwich to have a satisfying and tasty
meal for me this album is the good
quality ham and cheese sandwich nothing
overly fancy but very well written
engaging good production the album shows
the versatility of the band it's up an
upbeat album doesn't overstay its
welcome
and encourages me to hit the repeat
button when it's finished overall a
great example of the classic metal genre
worth noting the efforts of rudolf
schenker in particular people often say
that schenker has been a huge influence
on metal guitar my answer is witch
shanker uh rudolph is frequently
overshadowed by michael right which is i
think of course somewhat unjustified and
you know scott and i have talked about
this before i think that that rudolph
schenker
um certainly in the early scorpions era
one of the best um songwriters you know
and and willing to step back and be the
rhythm guitarist and just you know be
the the leader of the band essentially
so i agree with that
i will say this album the first time
that i started listening to it by the
time that i got to the fourth track and
i actually texted scott i was at the gym
i was like
i'm not listening to any more of this
because this is um it's you know it's
the scorpions but it's it's not really
good it's just kind of like we're
talking about phoning it in
i kind of felt like the first four
tracks were like that where and you know
the scorpion's good
is better than a lot of bands great
but it wasn't none of it was great
and then um i listened to it
listen to track five and i was like oh
well this is this is actually quite good
which is interesting because that one
that's got the reggae groove and they
make it work right well you know they've
done that in in you know um
back in the day in the 80s right there
there were a few songs where they would
pull that off and it's got a heavy
groove that's that's alternating with
those reggae uh softer verses and so i
was like this is good and then i
listened to track six seventh sun
yeah and
that one i was like wow this is like a
china white for
2022. you know it's got that boom boom
you know
there's nothing fancy about the baseline
then again there's nothing fancy about
you know the same bass line in uh
running with the devil but it's perfect
oh god
right
you know i put that you know you know uh
intro like eight uh like um
uh running with the devil i put is like
the what it reminded me of very simple
but it drives it yeah
like you know that goes back to what ken
said
you know sometimes a ham and cheese
sandwiches
you know i i agree you don't need to put
every ingredient in it right yeah just
yeah um
if you put in what's needed sometimes
it's a lot sometimes it's a little but
never
that's where people write either ego
based
um
like i unpopularly say that
up until moving pictures most of rush
was just throwing everything in there
and experimenting which they needed to
do
yeah um but i wasn't a big fan of 2112.
i just thought they were
a bunch of kids experimenting which is
necessary but i didn't love the um so
as far as this stuff it's kind of like
yeah it's like this is all you need here
i mean you could say that that's part of
what makes this album uneven is they
played it safe on a lot of songs yeah
they did they did good work you know but
it's just kind of well yeah okay that's
a scorpion song you know
um
i didn't like um the power ballad
that a lot of people seem to have like
when you know where you come from
um because i thought it was kind of
trite you know
um be true to yourself it's your life
and and i i just didn't find it that
that interesting the songs that i liked
were mostly ones where um
it sounded like
older scorpion stuff
that had somehow been updated like
when tomorrow comes
um
you know it's like it's like the 1970s
scorpion song like uh taken by force or
in trance era where you've got this
really raw
heavy
sound to it with a spoken word
yeah and then and then you know mine
comes in and he's he's
his he's still got the pipes and he
really uses it on that and then there's
versus where he's singing
and it's just the bass and the drums and
then the guitars come in with like the
wall of you know yeah all the sound kind
of thing
um i thought that was that was
one of the standout pieces
on it you know
yeah i you know overall i was kind of
disappointed there was some stuff i did
like um
the rhythm playing is awesome
you know they're both right with the
plays here's something nitpicky that i'm
going to say that bothered me
okay
mathias jabs is an unreal guitar player
i think he's one of the he's a great
great yeah but on this album
so a lot of his leads have some timing
issues and i'm surprised he didn't
reshoot it
you know i'm surprised that you know uh
i'm surprised he didn't go i can i could
do that better or somebody didn't point
out that
you're rushing this because you know the
classic albums that they recorded on two
inch tape he's always on the money he's
got great time he's got a great elastic
feel he's got this grease and what a
great guitar player i was shocked to
hear
it almost sounded like he was maybe he's
struggling physically to play right now
i mean i don't know how old he is or
what happened but well you know that i
mean that's something
we were talking about a little bit
earlier you know these these bands these
classic metal bands are
in their 60s and 70s and you know with
i mean like drumming you can't be i
don't think there's any drummers out
there that are in their 70s still
playing
vocalists okay we've got to have
adaptations for that um you know the
base makes its own demands but to be a
guitarist
i don't know there's there's some things
i mean that's that's part of what we saw
with in the case of glenn tipton
obviously has parkinson's but
um
and that's just you know putting the
whole kibosh on things but i i think
maybe in a lot of cases you can't keep
keep up this the same sort of thing that
you're you're used to well it's fine
fine muscle skills you know playing
guitar or bass it's not um yeah but if
you just if you develop
well there's the obvious ones like
tendonitis or carpal tunnel but if you
start getting um arthritis yeah um you
know i know some people that are older
that still play great but they're like i
can't play
the the the speed i used to play at so i
have to adapt to that and which is fine
um
you know a lot of times when people get
older they
they they might choose not to play as
much or they might go in a new direction
which is an interesting thing that's
come up in some of the comments for all
this stuff is uh
have the bands evolved into something
are they trying to rehash the path
yeah
and robert plant i think was a good
example i think that album i saw the
tory did a lot of it
the the last album was fantastic was it
a zeppelin album no but he's not a crazy
20 year old anymore either
you know um yeah
and i i don't mind as long as it's
really good um
but yeah i mean this album it would i
mean
it was just it's solid i mean the
performances on all these albums were
really good the content though on this
one is like there's a few things i like
but i probably wouldn't buy it and
listen to it
i guess it's the yeah i mean i
i would listen to some of the songs
as standouts
but yeah it's not it's not a scorpion's
album now ken says it's a great album to
sing along to while driving yeah so
while while you're
you're doing something else um
it's not i mean
you could put it up against like say
blackout you know or love it for staying
or or taken by force and you'd be like
no these earlier ones they they were
just like knocking out out of the park
then and this is
it's it's delivering but it's not
it's not uh
at that level
let's talk about another
another one though where we've got a
band that really is quite on fire um
also new wave of british heavy metal has
been around a very long time we've
mentioned them already saxon
they have a new album out called carpe
diem in 2022 and they also had an album
thunderbolt in 2018 when we talked about
seeing judas priest on tour that saxon
is also
touring with their thunderbolt album
this album uh we didn't actually solicit
any any uh fan feedback on that we did
we didn't have quite enough time um but
there's a lot of things to say about
this this album other than the fact that
the album art
not the best um but the the music i
think is is excellent
um
there's there's i will say this though
there's quite a few songs
um you could be like is this a saxon
song or is this also a judas priest song
you know
and like a contemporary judas priest
song
i'm not saying that they're like you
know
copying or anything like that i i just
think they happen to be moving in in a
similar
groove
um
and they're all shorter songs ken says
uh saxon are on fire at the moment great
sneak production and great songwriting
oh is is andy snape producing their
albums that would explain
a similarity and sound wouldn't it
because he's you know i didn't realize
he's the judas priest guy
um that's interesting i you know that's
what we get for not having the album in
our hands exactly yeah
now one thing i do want to point out
this is a pretty short album ten tracks
and the only song that's longer than
five minutes is actually my favorite
song off of it the pilgrimage
i love that one yeah that's that's a
real standout
um
i mean it's not like they were aiming
for radio airplay because they're not
going to get it they're saxon
i mean they've had it before
occasionally but
they they're kind of stuck in the
heavy metal
uh
uh you know radio ghetto like like
everybody else i think um from from
their time
um
but you know there's some really good
songs on there i i thought um carpe diem
the title track it's got everything that
you'd want it to have it's heavy it's
tight it's got some nice solos on it
the one right after it
you know fulfills saxon's requirement
that they seem to have
every album has to have at least one
song that's about a mode of
transportation
and it's called the age of steam
but it's you know it's a good heavy
every single song on it's got got good
heavy um riffs and and nice hooks um the
fun the the funny line from it here
comes the revolution here comes the age
of steam you know
and then there's the pilgrimage track
three um right
and one of the things that i thought was
really cool about this album is um
they have a song about covet
called remember the fallen
yeah
you know um not a lot of i don't see a
lot of
people singing about that
you know that's really interesting point
actually you know what
and i wonder
um
i'm actually surprised it hasn't been a
bigger subject right
yeah um
i mean they frame it in terms of like
heroism and stuff like that because you
know it's saxon um oh yeah triumphant
exactly yeah
but i mean it's a good metal song
um
yeah i mean
there's great riffs and it's funny
because i have note like the the one um
is it all for one
that's another good one right but it's
kind of like stand up and shout that
guitar riff is is a bit like d.o stand
up and shout huh and it i mean um the
two doesn't go in to stand up and chat
of course
but i think the band sounds great and
here's i i actually said this band the
drums are amazing the band is so tight i
went yeah and there was a pro shot
concert
from recently
and these guys look really old but they
are playing their asses off the band
i think what ken says they are top form
that is a band and um just the grooves
alone and that's so important like you
know sometimes we take that for granted
like you know in jazz if you don't swing
it's nothing like he doesn't have any
feel no matter the composition well we
grew up with rock we take it for granted
that you know if you if jazz players
said oh all we need is distortion and a
power chord we'd be like you guys don't
know how to rock
you know yeah but saxon
um on fire i mean um
i'd pay to go see them in a heartbeat
you know we we have seen them uh twice
recently and if they come back here you
know we're definitely gonna see them
because they put on a great show
uh like you said they're very high
energy um i mean biff byford i think is
70. yeah and he
i think
you know of all the people that we've
talked about so far
maybe he's got the best preserved voice
out i mean he's these are and he's and
he brings it live i mean i'm watching
this video and he's uh he's not messing
around and i love it and it's um andy
says he's 71 yeah
yeah so yeah i'm gonna try to catch
saxon if they come by here
definitely would pay nearly anything to
see
through facts and do a concert together
you know what that's a great bill ken
yeah now you're probably not going to
see anything like that um except at a
festival i imagine right where there's a
whole bunch of
other bands but yeah that would be that
would be pretty awesome um i mean
imagine if you put together like a
a uh
yeah andy points out we saw saxon open
for for priest uh the first time we can
we can easily align the stars with two
of these bands but getting all three
onto the same bill that might be very
difficult to do
um
what else do you want to say about the
saxon album um
i mean
some highlights i like supernova
um yeah
um
i like that one i i actually put in
there that could be a contemporary
priest song um and it's got you know
softer interlude with a lyrical guitar
scene exactly yeah that's you know and i
think some of the arranging is really
thoughtful instead of going here's a
riff
we'll do a course and we'll do a solo
and then we'll go out
it was kind of like somebody said well
it's almost like they sat in
the old way of like sitting at the
rehearsal space going well what if we
tried this
and um there's something to be said for
that old model of writing where you all
sit in the room together and somebody
brings an idea
and you work it out i don't know if
that's how they did it you'd have to ask
them but um it could also be the the
producer saying guys right here we need
something that does this and then they
can come up with it
so whatever whatever um
the end uh i i just think you know
the best part for me is hearing how good
the band sounds and i think you know
they're old school they tr they tracked
at least the rhythm section live i'll
tell you that because that's not
something you
you know that's something to get that
kind of groove
you know you have to be playing together
a long time
yeah
i will say too that their their 2018
thunderbolt um
was
just as good as as um carpe diem i'd say
they're really on the same level yeah
and i haven't heard but i'll have to
check it out
yeah it was i mean that's what they were
supporting as when they were lined up
with priest um well let me ask you did
we play a decent amount from that record
well that's so
a little bit of a digression here we saw
them uh
two separate nights
and on the first um
night it was a three bill thing it was
black star rider which is basically
what used to be
the
remnants of thin lizzy you know scott
gorham and and his band touring and then
when they made new stuff they called it
black star writer um so they got to do
like maybe
six seven songs then saxon came on and
did eight songs and they did they did do
you know uh thunderbolt um
nosferatu from from that album and maybe
another newer one as well but they had
to pack in the fan favorites like you
know wheels of steel and um
you know uh
uh denim and leather yeah that sort of
thing
um and then priests did like their whole
14 to 15 song set so it was quite a long
night but then the next night i think it
was and andy can tell me if i'm if it
was the next night or the night after
we saw them at the pottawatomie casino
and it was just saxon and black star
rider and saxon was the headliner in
that case so i think they played like
about 14 songs
that time
and um
it was a good mix i mean saxon by that
time i think i want to say thunderbolt
was like album number number 17 so you
know
there's a lot of a huge catalog to play
from
sure andy says it was the very next
night yeah saxon like hung around
and so did black star rider after priest
moved on to the next place oh cool oh
that was that was quite quite
interesting yeah
that's cool well we should jump ahead um
now
one that that you know
i'd be very interested to get get your
take on scott is blue easter cult's uh
newest album first in i think 20 years
right the symbol remains
and
you know my overall impressions were i
would say
you know like with blue easter cult in
general it's it's not a metal album
where it's like back to back metal right
but there are some definite like metal
standout songs on it
right
right um well um
it even kind of like uh
um tainted blood is not a heavy metal
song but the progression is
kind of a metal type uh
yeah it's kind of a powerballity song
it's not a power ballad as such but
right but it is yeah and um it's about
vampires by the way yeah
the standout line that i actually wrote
down there no one to wipe my bloody
tears
and the alchemist is a great oh
that may be the best song on the album
it's just and you know that's in the set
um and i love the opening track that was
me it's just
you know uh yeah the vocal content is
perfect as far as you know
you know uh you know him being proud of
him being a rebel and um
that's kind of like the the the eric
bloom
that we always loved like the the blues
man rants kind of you know that he's
been doing a little bit more of now but
um
most of the album i thought was just
amazing but then you get something
that's clearly almost pop like box in my
head
right right yeah it's like a buck dharma
kind of thing so
um i don't think it's funny because he
they always say we're not
we're not pioneers of metal we come from
the hate ashbury jefferson airplane you
know grateful dead which is like i don't
hear that but
yeah maybe that maybe that's how they
think of themselves but they veer into
metal whether they mean to or not you
know i mean that first album really
heavy rifts yeah um but like you know
they they have no problem going in and
out of a heavy riff and doing it like
champs and then going into something
completely
you know
different although something holds the
whole album together
that's i i was going to ask you about
that to me it it's sort of like well you
know we'll throw in a heavy song then a
poppier song then you know do this i
didn't see a um
a complete continuity to it but maybe i
need to listen to it a couple more
times
i mean
um
yeah i mean i guess there's some things
to these albums that it's so heavy all
the time that it's like i can tune out
okay you know it's like let's just write
you know
14 punch in the face metal riffs and um
and
um see me and more like like the judas
priest one or the saxon one that we were
discussing where it is mostly or even
the iron maiden one you know it's all
metal all the time yeah but if you're
gonna do that the songs better be
amazing because sonically i'm gonna get
tired yeah um you know if you beat
someone over the head long enough
uh they're not gonna feel it after or
you hit someone punch someone not gonna
feel it after a while it's you know
yeah i mean and and there's like a wide
range of stuff on this um
you know box in my head is probably the
poppiest song
yep um nightmare epiphany is kind of a
jazzy song i really like the bassline on
it you know yeah i don't know the place
um what else there's
a weird one to me is true train
there if there was one that i would take
off
the album it would be that and they've
been doing that live and um
that's one of their five i mean we
should say why the song is so weird i
mean it begins with a train whistle and
you'd be like okay well that's a nice
starting thing and then they use it
throughout the song
and it starts off being this bluesy song
and then it like
switches to faster time
it's like a double-time country thing
almost and there's a lot of words
and it's all about
the trains
you know
it's just yeah and they do it live and i
go oh this doesn't fit anywhere in the
set to me i mean
um
is it a palette cleanser is it uh
well i just thought it was interesting
because
i saw them a few times and i said you
only you didn't do anything from the
album it just came out well you know it
was coming out of covet i mean that
album yeah and little by little
um
they started adding stuff and the last
time i saw them there was five solid
songs from it and um you know the
alchemist one of them of course
that was me
um
you know things i think are pretty hot
like for tunes on the album yeah but
true train would just seem
um
[Music]
i mean they have their reasons i i you
know i if this were back in the day that
would be a b side
you know the back of the day that would
be a filler
you know like remember when bands would
do something completely out of just to
make the 40 minute mark because
you got an lp
but ken says the track made me wonder if
the bander actually trained fans
actually
i think so
uh yeah right uh
you know i know um richie and eric bloom
are huge gamers believe it or not and
eric bloom's a sci-fi nut and that's why
like the the old blue oyster cult songs
yeah were all about science fiction well
you know so that's a good segue to
talking about edge of the world um which
i think is one of the best songs on
there i mean the alchemist i think is
the best song yeah alchemist is amazing
but edge of the world is really kind of
cool because you don't realize until
you're a good ways into it like actually
paying attention to the lyric this guy's
been abducted by aliens and he's trying
to communicate his experience
it's it's a lovely song with a great
hook and a wonderful
chorus and you know there's great guitar
and keyboards on it and then you're like
holy crap this guy's talking about this
horrific experience
it's it's kind of like a remember the
the tune they had to take me away from
revolution by night was really
you know just challenging aliens take me
you know i want to go on an adventure
this is a little different but you know
it's like extraterrestrial intelligence
from ages of fortune you know they do
talk about extraterrestrials or you know
being abducted or uh yeah
here's a really interesting point by ken
um i've always wondered if bloister cult
would have become a sci-fi program act
if they'd continued over the years
that's a good point you know um
you know i know and that's eric's thing
eric bloom is very much into that and
you know of course bucks tunes are about
other things
like even burning for you right yeah um
you know like he he'd have like the pop
rock tunes which i think i always call
buck hits because he writes a great pop
tune
you know um but you know eric's
definitely um
i think
a song that kind of combines those is
the machine
because it's not um it's more aor than
metal right but it's this very dystopian
i'm a slave to the machine but it's very
clever lyrics right
yeah you know is that is that one where
where it's buck writing the lyrics or
for eric you know i don't know i i i i
have the vinyl like i got that when uh
the pre-seal for vinyl but you know the
albums before uh heaven forbid
i think with the one before it and then
there was two albums you know i think
the last one was early 2000 2001 but um
they were okay
i didn't like but this album i really
got excited about
you know
i like this one um there's an for me
there's there's enough
stuff that really is metal i mean i i
can count
um i would say
if we're being generous one
two
three four
five six six songs on a 14 track album
are arguably metal yeah you know
and then some of the other ones are
still kind of kind of hard um i mean and
then the other ones are groovy you know
yeah the sort of thing you like i mean
um don't fear the reaper is not a metal
song but it's still you know really nice
to listen to florida man is kind of like
that
yo yeah yeah right florida man that's a
um
that's interesting i just think
listening to it it's just kind of like
i think if they think it's good it's
going to go on the album and
at the stage of their career um i really
feel like uh
as long as they're being honest with us
it's gonna be good
yeah
uh so i you know i
heaven forbid that was you know uh curse
of the hidden mirror with the last two
and those were fine albums but
you know they only play one song from
uh live they always play um heaven
forbid i don't know why that's the one
they play um
there's a song that they play a harvest
moon and it's you know every show that's
a fan favorite from
the album from 2000 which is interesting
i wonder well i don't know how much
longer they're going to be doing this
but right i mean that's a good point i
mean with with uh bluester cult we're
talking about a band we're reaching now
back into the
early 70s
right when their their first stuff is
coming out and that's two yeah and so
that's a great segue into a yet older
band uh which only has one original
member left uh the guitarist mcbox and
band leader uriah heap
who we we also saw with judas priest
andy and i used to joke around that you
know um seeing judas priests was like
becoming the consolation prize because
they were touring so much with all these
other great bands that we wanted to see
but uriah he put out an album living the
dream in 2018 and it's a it's a great
album um
ken uh actually weighed in on this
earlier saying along with ufo they were
the progenitors of so many new wave of
british heavy metal bands i think that's
completely right i agree
ufo deep purple black sabbath you know
uriah heap and d purple actually were
recording in the same studio in
different rooms on on early stuff and
there's so much continuity in the early
like ferment that that creates heavy
metal and then leads to the new wave of
british heavy metal so he says i feel
genuinely privileged to have been there
in the early days of it the regular
excitement of opening a new tape from
bands like made in sacks
um so many great bands
heap very much influenced most if not
all of them i i think that's completely
right you know and there that
you know i totally agree with that and
it's a mystery to me why they're
people don't talk about them or they're
not familiar with them who are you know
well should i go off on one of my rants
so there's this narrative that gets put
out there
and it's it you know um rob helford
unfortunately does this in a
self-serving way even on stage sometimes
and there's like music writers who do
this and a lot of younger people don't
know this they don't know that the
narrative is false and the narrative
runs like this you know there was like
proto-heavy metal and then there was
black sabbath and the reason why they
played the way that they did was because
of tony aomi's finger you know and they
were like the only band really doing
that well there was led zeppelin and
deep purple but they weren't really
metal it was black sabbath and then they
were alone in the wilderness this entire
time until judas priest took up the
mantle in the mid 70s and then you know
everything boomed after that and if you
know anything about music history you're
like okay so there's there's two ways
that this is complete
[ __ ] actually three ways right let's
just take the british scene
yes in in 1970 black sabbath puts out
two albums and d purple also you know is
bringing something out and uriah heap
and ufo right and they're all part of
this like heavy sound
that is equally contributing to things
um within like the 19 this is something
scott and i actually did a show on right
1970 to 1974 there's all these bands
that are doing stuff that's going to be
metal in the british scene and then you
know there's also american bands right
montrose is doing metal right
um you know we've got uh other things
happen you know sir lord baltimore who
toured with with sabbath the scorpions
are starting to you know get their act
together and so this like oh in the
1970s it was just sabbath and then it
was us [ __ ] you know and then it it
ignores the fact that like you know
motorhead was there too right and all
these other bands that were there and so
ken says people think that metal was
sabbath to priests to maiden and
everyone else and and i think
i hear that all the time there's a lot
of disinformation and the i think
younger people who are interested in
metal who are getting introduced to it
largely through the genres you know that
have have spiraled out then they they
you know google and they they see
somebody saying yes it was a black
sabbath and then it was
it was um
uh uh you know judas priest and that was
it
how do they know you know and so uriah
heap was one of those key bands that
like ken is pointing out all these
people were listening to uriah you know
or they're listening to deep purple like
bruce dickinson doesn't say
oh i you know i wanted to be like ozzy
he says i wanted to be like ian gillan
steve harris didn't say i want to be
like eazer butler he said i want to be
like pete way you know that's true
but the uri thing is such a
it's it's kind of a mystery in bringing
and and listening to this album that
really brought that back to the surface
for me how great this record is yeah and
um
uh
you know and then going back and going
you know like they don't i don't think i
think they're you know
they're just you know by so many people
they're kicked to the curb whether they
don't know any better yeah yeah and i
think that's what you're saying is kind
of like
you know if rob halford's saying it
everybody our age and
or after kind of like oh well rob
halford said it or not to put it all on
him but he's not the only one yeah but
they're like encyclopedias of heavy
metal that put this out there as well
you know
yeah fortunately so there's here's
another thing that that um uh ken says
that i think is is like totally dead on
there's much to like on living the dream
classic heavy rock at its very best i'd
say that fans of dio air era rainbow
will be right at home with this album i
i think that's that's completely right i
agree with that and and yo era rainbow
is inheriting stuff from deep purple
there's there's some purple-esque
elements to this songwriting is strong
as always from heap production is
excellent bernie sounds as good as he
ever did
um i can't pick a standout track that's
that's but that's more of a product of
the fact that their songwriting is
consistently
good
um and yeah it's uh it's one of those
albums that i think a lot of people
probably
unless they hear somebody recommending
it they're not going to give it a chance
you know it's a good point that's a
really good point actually yeah they're
one of those bands that like people
might check out the new priest but right
you know uh
but it but i i would tell people
this is really worth your your time or
your while
it it's kind of
got all the things that a good
uriah heap album has you know really
heavy songs where the organ is playing a
major major role i love it and you know
mick box on guitar is
is you know still great
fantastic plane um
there's you know there's there's a
couple
proge songs like rocks in the road i
would say is
more progy than anything else
waters flowing is is a softer kind of
old-school heat ballad about you know
people coming for miles around to listen
to this
this guitarist with his great sound he
plays down by the water you know i mean
basically every
heap album has a
acoustic kind of song on it like that
but then the rest like raised by heaven
really great uh uh starting song my
favorite is take away my soul which they
played in uh in concert oh interesting i
was going to ask you know that's another
thing we should have been keeping tabs
with
our favorites which ones are they
playing yeah yeah but that's really cool
because i you know i wonder when they
decide which one's for the new album to
play do they see it on forums like
everybody kind of votes or
that's a good question i mean when i s
when we saw them they were supporting
priests so i think they got to play
maybe 10 songs
and again you know they've got a huge
catalog sort of like loister cult or
like saxon where they got a you know you
can't do a heap concert without playing
gypsy right
or
uh i don't know if they played bird of
prey but you know some of the older
stuff where you got to play those they
did play grazed by heaven
um i think they may have actually opened
with that
oh cool or or with take away my soul
um i don't remember any of the other
songs being played but you know two out
of ten
not bad
um ken says uh i can't say enough good
things about this heap album of all the
these albums the one i've had on
constant repeats since yesterday has
been this one
yeah it is it's a very listenable album
it's not one i think that we're gonna
get bored with
no i agree with that that's you know um
i still do buy music but sometimes it's
kind of like uh
um am i gonna listen to this
and this one yes uh the priest yes
you know um
yeah so it's kind of like i you know
having it on repeat yeah i'll listen to
that in the car or i'll listen to it
when i have some time off it's you know
it's great especially that this is
the band today we're lucky enough to
hear these bands writing and putting
music out today well you know that's
another good point i mean when we saw
them performing
um
most i mean it's not all original
members in the band except for mcbox but
they're all pretty most of them are as
old as mcbox
right and
um you know the organist is like just on
fire while they're playing i think they
have a younger drummer and i think they
have a younger bassist
um i'm gonna have to look up some live
stuff just to check it out the way i did
with saxon yeah
yeah but they they they really um
they in concert it was a pretty amazing
performance they weren't phoning it in
in any any way that's amazing you know
that would that would be a
disappointment i think um there's going
to be a band where yeah
this the the i guess the 14 15 16 year
old still in me where
um
where if i well you know i was really
disappointed i went to
one boyfriend cult show and eric bloom
was sick
no rants no godzilla ants no
you know pointing out of the crowd no
you know i love that stuff i love the
showmanship i love that's part of what
rock and roll is is you go into trouble
and it's like you know that nowadays
rock bands you know kids look like they
came out of a bar that are playing like
uh they've got like you know they're not
really dressed for anything there's
they don't you know nothing looks cool
there's no concept there's no world to
subscribe to and i think that's
something that's kind of cool
love it or not the the theme of an album
they're they're they're giving you some
kind they get together and they have
some kind of concept
right you know one somebody who we're
going to look at later on in another
like album review thing
um who just has the best time on stage
uh when we've seen him is udo dirk
schneider oh yeah you know he's an old
guy little squat you know bald german
guy
who surrounds himself with younger
musicians who are all they're all into
playing his stuff and playing the uh
um
the classic except stuff but i think
he's not doing any any more
except stuff we we saw him a while back
but the um
joy that he has
in being up there and doing these songs
it's like it's like a wave that goes out
to the audience it is amazing i agree
and ken says you know uh ken ken agrees
to that um
you know
i see some of the younger bands and you
know uh i hate when people say well
you're old-fashioned that's kind of
ageism right
um you know like well the new thing is
you know we don't want to make a world
we don't it's just about the music man
well
you know it's it's about a lot of things
rock and roll can be a lifestyle yeah
you know it can be a world to escape to
i mean look movies it's like we're gonna
we're gonna get people that can't act
we're gonna get people like you know
there's the but the contents there yeah
you know it's like part of the
experience going to the show and having
that unity of everybody around you you
don't know
you're all like
you know there's 10 000 of you going oh
yeah they're doing this one and i find
that now it shows you know people my age
or older than me they were like oh i
can't believe they're doing this one or
there's that whole unity and that whole
the band is
uh
doing something in their in in their
performance that's that's
i still relate to i didn't grow out of
it because as people say you should grow
out of it no well i mean
when when i go to the grocery store i
still um
while i'm taking the card out to the car
start you know pushing it fast and ride
it down there i think there's quite a
few things like that in our lives that
you know if we were like an earlier
generation maybe we'd be like too
ashamed to do that or
some some yet older people would be like
knock that off right but but now we we
get to you know we get to revel in that
there is one other band that we are
going to uh look at and you know they
they're a band that started out as glam
but have expanded considerably led by
tracy guns uh the lead guitarist he's
the constantine and that's la guns
and i do want to note that um they've
been very prolific we're reviewing
checkered pass which is uh
2021
but in the last six years they have put
out four albums missing piece the devil
you know and renegades
it seems to be a pretty stable lineup
which is good
their bassist is a uh certainly on
on uh checkered past is a studio basis
he's not the touring guy which is kind
of
interesting i didn't know it does a lot
of music producing
um and it's it's a um
so you know we scott and i both gave
this a a listen i enjoyed it i was you
know i was back in the day i was not
listening a lot to
la guns but i thought you know we should
check it out because
you know they're doing a lot of work and
uh maybe we shouldn't just all be you
know um british bands and you know with
the scorpions thrown in
um
there were some some songs that i i
liked some that i was less into
um
they they managed to put in a countryish
kind of ballad on track four that i that
that's not i was you know
i'm not into that kind of kind of stuff
but there's some that are that are quite
good on there i think too
um well yeah like i didn't like uh get
along i didn't like i didn't like the
folk your tunes but i thought the hot
spot was bad luck charm that was that's
great that's cool that was my favorite
tune on the album that was the one
earlier i said there was one where it
sounded like uh he was channeling um an
iron maiden guitarist maybe adrian smith
or dave murray on the solo yeah
yeah it's got that sound to it it's a
it's a great
you know and bad luck charm is kind of a
blues title so it's kind of like
this like heavy guitar it was a good
really good riff that i think that's the
second track right i just it is yeah
it's it and then i was like this is
going to be cool and then the rest of it
went to that kind of borderline folky
yeah yeah rock where it was like
you know to me it just didn't uh i had
to listen to it in a few different
i couldn't listen to the whole thing all
the way through
oh really you mean i mean
i i i yeah like i jumped off after the
third song and then okay
because i i started to kind of blur it
out and i wasn't going to give it a fair
i wasn't giving the songs a fair listen
because i'm like i'm tired already you
know
which is interesting um
yeah i did think bad luck charm is is a
notable great tune that you know if
they're going to keep going on that that
should be in their set all the time i i
liked um
better than you as well and and
cannonball
um i thought those were pretty good that
ain't wise it got got a nice baseline to
it
um
there were a few where like like living
right now the third track it starts on
it seems like a all over the place and
then by the end it got it got better
but maybe maybe part part of what's like
making this work is
tracy guns guitar solos you know it's
showcasing
his abilities in that you know so
you're a little bit more forgiving
about that yeah i mean uh the
performance
on the album is good i mean it's it's
pro quality playing yeah you know i
don't want to dismiss this album it's
not inspired no it's no it's not not
like uh how i felt about um
like i was like saxon before you know
some of it was just kind of they
captured uh
yeah they captured like uh yeah
you're there you're there you're still
there you know yeah ken says pretty good
album i wish they stopped the revolving
door of band members and maybe that's
part of it i mean
if your bassist is a studio guy that
you're not going to tour with
you know can you really gel as a band
you know
what's the same way it's a good it's a
really good point because
if you've been playing a long time with
somebody i always use you too because
everybody's like well you know
this guy's the best bass player well or
you know neil pertz the best drummer
well no i mean he's the best drummer for
rush yeah he was the best or you know
it's
um
you wouldn't slip him into quiet riot
and get quite the same results
he sounds great in in rush because the
band plays great together right you know
or uh and some of the bands that we're
looking at here have had stable lineups
where there have been a few people
coming in and out but for the most part
the band is the same for for at least 15
to 20 years like you riot heap for
example you know
um yeah yeah and even five years is
notable if you've been playing together
it's it's not like so i use youtube
because those early albums are
unbelievable and i remember when you two
came out in the early 80s everybody's
like oh they can't play their
instruments
and i'm like this sounds pretty amazing
to me and it's not about you know the
drummer wanting to do the most
crazy drum solo or the bass but the
sounds were amazing the edge is the
genius and i was like they sound good
because they play together a lot you
don't pull them out and do a drum clinic
yeah
i mean the earliest stuff um was was
kind of i'm not going to say minimalist
but there was a rawness to it yeah and
the guitar sound evolved to the joshua
tree which is what i consider to be
their their like height um i didn't
really like the stuff that came after
no i had a hard time with pop and uh
yeah from baby like i had a really hard
time when they went there i mean i
respected that they did something
different but yeah
they kind of lost heart to me but i'm
no disrespect to
them trying to i will say two things
that are that are kind of um critical
about the lyrics of these these uh songs
on checkered past
so
track number eight uh dog it's a good
groovy heavy song yeah there's way way
too much gonna be my dog
you know is there's a line in there i
mean it's it's uh
it became like a filler basically right
and then there's this other song that's
a good point
more like 80s garage rock sounding knock
me down and it's kind of an anthem it's
not really a metal song
when you listen to the lyrics these
sound like a just a horrible couple you
know you're you're like oh man i don't
know if i like this um certainly isn't
something i'd want to sing along to you
know right i mean it's one thing to like
have uh you know dave mustain joking
around on p cells who's buying you know
i'm not kind i'm not your kind that sort
of thing yeah this is just like
relentless negativity you know
no it's a that's a really good point and
i like your point about filler we don't
really have filler tracks but we can
have filler lyrics like oh yeah yeah
when you when you hum things here's the
melody well what happens with these
three beats i don't know i'll say this
again
it's there's three syllables there
yeah that's a good point i you know uh i
didn't think of that but i agree i mean
if you have three syllables you can
always say oh baby yeah exactly
that's the that's the that's the um
allowed filler exactly yeah
so you know um most of the albums that
we've reviewed you know were
mostly positive about i'd say
yeah
the scorpions won maybe a little bit
less so the la guns
a little bit less so but still all worth
worth checking out you know
um
i'm glad i checked them out either you
know either way i'm glad yeah there
weren't any like real stinkers in there
so no
no but there's definitely uh reviewing
that many or i should say listening to
that many you see who's really um
because you know they're capable of
doing amazing things all of them because
they have right right right
who who's going to put in the time or
who's going to be like well we just need
to put something out to you know let's
just put something out well and they're
kind of like you know they're their neck
and neck right we can we can say uh okay
this judas priest album is really great
is made in measuring up to that you know
right
so yeah but i think both you know really
really did an amazing job i mean
and saxon if we're if we're talking
about that that era of british metal you
know saxon yeah maiden you know it took
me a while to get into the album it's
not my favorite made now by any stretch
but it but it's a well played well done
well thought out album you know and i
think like it or not if i can listen to
this i'm going wow this is this is
top-notch playing this is top-notch
thought thinking then you know uh it
doesn't matter if i don't want to listen
to it it's they did a really good job
yeah i will say this too about the the
writing on the wall um
i saw the video first with the music
and that kind of soured me on it because
the video was just such a hot mess of
way too much stuff going on
and um listening to it without the video
once you get past the twangy country
thing
it's pretty good you know yeah
yeah so
well we should uh wrap this up it's
getting uh we're way past time um thanks
to everybody who joined us and
especially thanks to ken for all these
really great yeah
insights and comments those uh uh
well valued
and we're gonna do some more of these uh
like i said in the future with like new
wave of british heavy metal uh
in particular and then some some other
genres as well some other we'll figure
out what we're going to call the genres
but yeah thanks
for for joining us uh this has been very
enjoyable it's i think this is kind of a
cool thing to do to check out these
these uh new
offerings and not just like remain way
back in the past you know oh i'm only
going to listen to peace of mind
i agree i agree yeah
awesome all right well we'll see y'all
take care
you